did donald trump win or lose the  election and the answer is he lost  and you can not like joe biden and you  can say listen neil  the people spoke and it wasn't even that  close joe biden won and that's it they  still can't even acknowledge that they  may never acknowledge it they're they're  not seemingly getting over this  but moore actually goes a step further  and says  it may be an unknowable thing we may  never know who actually won the election  which is like an extra little wrinkle to  the thing which is i'm i'm not saying  trump definitely won but i'm certainly  not saying trump lost  but i'm adding on to it  we won't know which is exactly how these  people will cling to the belief that  maybe trump won when you start hearing  people say it's unknowable it's a you  are basically saying it's a matter of  opinion it's uh we we don't know we will  never know it's a scrambled egg you  can't unscramble an egg